- Hello, Korea.
How are you doing?
I'm very happy to meet you all.
Hope you're all having a
fantastic day at JSConf Korea.
First of all,
I want to thank all the
organizers of this conference
for all the hard work they've put in
to make this conference possible
despite the current global circumstances.
Unfortunately, I can't be there in person,
but I'm so happy that I can reach out
to you all in this medium.
I'm here to talk about
how we can make the life of
our developers much easier,
who work on large monorepos.
A monorepo or a mono-repository
is a single repository
that stores all of your code
and assets for every project.
We will look at JavaScript
monorepo throughout this talk.
In the beginning, we
will try to understand
what are some of the reasons
why we opted for, you know,
like a monorepo structure for our code.
Then we look at some of
the tooling and techniques
which can help you be more
productive with monorepos.
I am Jai Santhosh
and I work as an engineering
manager at Microsoft.
I am available on Twitter
and my handle is @jaisanth.
I'm from this beautiful city
of Bangalore in South India.
Usually the traffic is much more
than what you can see
in that illustration.
At Microsoft I work on a
product called Microsoft Search,
where we built unified search
experiences for, you know,
like all your work related content
across Microsoft 365 Apps
suite, Windows and Bing.
When you look at the search product,
you can see that there
are multiple components
like the search box,
the search results page,
a lot of other components
which are shared across the products
so that we can achieve, you know,
a uniform experience for the
end user across the products.
Experiences like search
are what we considered
as High-Value Experiences,
which are critical operations
a user does across applications
and across platforms in the Office Suite.
We also need to be more coherent
to ensure the search
experiences also look consistent
with the rest of the application
and across various apps and platforms.
We have all the 400 developers
who work on this monorepo.
We also integrate the
components we develop
across the Microsoft Words
like Office SharePoint, Themes, et cetera.
And, you know, we mainly
call this as host apps.
Let's take the example of a
simpler high-value experience,
like the people card,
the people card started out
as a simpler contact information guide
all time it has started
growing in complexity.
So now you can see that it has
evolved in how it looks like
and how much more feature
rich it has become.
Let us understand it in a bit more detail.
You can see here that the people card
now consists of various
sections, such as insights,
it contains recent
activity, conversations,
shared documents between
you and the other person.
What are the upcoming
events between you two
and a lot more
apart from the contact
information of the user.
So it has actually evolved
and grown in intelligence
as well as how much information
it actually contains.
Also each section is actually expanded
into even more detailed components,
which are much much
more complex in nature.
Here, you can see that
there are very like deeper
conversations components
that you can see that contact information
also much more zoomed out.
And so then, like you
can have like documents
between the two people that you've shared,
or that you have access to.
You can have access to all
the events that are upcoming
or the ones that you've recently had.
The organization chart
information for you,
especially in large
companies is really useful.
And you will also have
a lot more analytics
and insights that you can get, right?
So the people card now ended up having
more than 20 categories of information.
Now let's look at what
we do as a developer
when we're developing
something like people card.
If you visualize agility,
we can see it is something like this.
We can break it into two loops,
the inner loop and the outer loop.
The inner loop is more of,
you know, a daily routine
where you write new code,
doesn't locally create a full request,
verify build and test reports
and merge it with the main branch.
The outer loop consists of actions
after the code is checked in, right?
So we deployed two different
rings to production,
listen and measure feedback,
propose what are the next steps
to improve a feature
or a certain component,
and then write code and go back
to inner loop again, right?
So now let's, if you just zoom out a bit,
you can see that how we
can map this in practice
for the people card scenario.
Here, the outer loop is actually
much more diverse, right.
So, it is a more than
any one given platform.
So scaling out is really necessary,
which works across the various platforms.
We actually developed two
six platforms as shown here,
like the web, the iOS, UWP, Mac,
MacOS, Win32 and so on.
In most cases the usual norm is that
each platform is typically
siloed for the UX
and development based
on code basing people.
Working across teams is very hard.
It does scatter your
developer environment,
cross repo changes or
rollback is very hard.
It is very difficult
to enforce conventions
across different repos.
Apart from all the software aspects,
the largest problem is
to tackle, you know,
the people aspect.
So we were working with, as I said,
more than 400 developers
across various teams
and all of these people may
not bide to the same goals.
Hence we looked at unifying the core basis
into a single source repository
and evaluate if it can
improve the develop rates tree
To summarize the people card
now has to be shared across
multiple applications
or host apps that we call
in the Office 365 Suite,
as well as across six platforms
in a cohesive way where,
you know, the people card
still remains people card,
but still has similar behavior
and kind of looks homogeneous
within each of these host apps
and also kind of brings in native usage
and intractability
patterns into the people,
to the same component.
So we need to find a way
to maximize deliberate agility here.
We started adding all of this code
to one single repository or monorepo
and this brought in more
singularity across packages.
Now, let's look at what
is a monorepo, right?
A monorepo is a repository
with multiple packages or projects.
It may not necessarily be a
colossal 86 terabyte monolith,
but somewhere where various projects
and packages can co-exist.
It also allows us to break
our code down to packages
with single responsibility
and hence multiple packages,
which are aggregated this
way can help in ensuring
that even in other repository
or the host apps repository
they can actually pick a
certain package and just use it.
For example, think of the people card
being used in a calendar
widget in Outlook, right?
So this way, it actually allows
for use of small packages
across multiple host apps
and other repositories.
Having all of this in a single repo
also helped us unify
process across packages,
make developers more agile,
achieve more code consistency.
So even for developers, new
developers who joined the team,
it was very easy for them to discover code
across the packages and that
way it was helpful to have
things in one place rather than scattered
in multiple repositories.
For our work on people card,
it looks something like this.
One thing we focused on was to ensure
we break all the code
down to smaller packages,
which are single responsibility.
You see, we were able
to achieve maximum reuse
across platforms.
For example, here we broke
the people card down into
people data, people-api,
people core, this can
then be shared centrally
across platforms specific packages,
like people-web, people-ios and so on.
So moving through a monorepo
meant that we absolutely need
and have reliable to link
across various categories
like package management,
cross-package orchestration,
linters, testing tools,
build system, infrastructure
and much more.
In this stack, we mainly look
at two of the hardest problems
of package management and
cross package orchestrators.
These are some things that are very basic
in the sense of monorepo
and something where we might end up
spending a lot more time and
lose up for activity, right?
Let's understand how we can
simplify package management
now in a JavaScript monorepo.
So JavaScript packages
are the building blocks
of any large JavaScript repo.
The repository that we've working
has over 150 to 200 internal packages.
We take a dependency of
over 2,500 external packages
for our components to
work well with each other
and with our partner repos,
we really need to manage
our packages really well.
Before we learn more about it,
let us first understand
how a package gets used.
The package.json file is actually read
by the package managers
such as NPM or Yarn,
when you require a certain
module in your JavaScript file
NodeJS will resolve this by
looking at the module on disk.
So the package manager
actually writes files to this
which then your NodeJS process
kind of looks at the files
that are on the disk.
So the key inside here is that
Node will not resolve anything
by looking at the package.json
but rather it will just look at the file
with node module resolution,
which is present on the disk.
It won't even verify that if
it is getting the right version
that is required or not, right?
So we need to just ensure
that the files on disk
are actually proper
and that's where Node can pick it up from.
So Node Module Resolution
is a key concept in Node.js.
The basic idea behind
this algorithm is started
a recursively looks at
of what a certain package
that is required.
Let's take an example,
say for module in the people-core
package depends on react,
Node we'll look for it in the react
in the node modules folder of people-core,
if it can't find it there,
it will look in the node_modules folder
of the parent of people-core and so on
all the way to the root of
your hard drive, right?`.
So now let's map this concept
in case of a monorepo.
I assume that we have two repositories
with package one, package
two with the monorepo,
you can see that like
both of these packages
come to the same folder
under a monorepo, right?
We want to look at a
few issues with monorepo
which probably we can solve
with our current understanding
of how Node resolves modules, right?
A concept package may just use
is sharing common dependencies on disk
because of the nature of monorepo
most packages will share many dependencies
and there can also be, you know,
like some packages can be
dependent on other packages
of within the monorepo itself.
So imagine having two
packages, Oh, like I said,
package one and package two.
We have three dependencies
here on package B,
and then we have two versions.
So say package one,
depends on packages A, C,
and then A internally it takes
a dependency on B of 1.0 version.
Package two also takes a
dependency on B, 1.0 version.
You can see here that package
C actually takes a dependency
on 2.0 version of B, not the 1.0 version.
So there are like three copies of B,
where we can do couple of
them, like B at 1.0 version,
but still retain to ensure that
C kind of takes a dependency
on the 2.0 version of package B, right?
So leveraging the node
module resolution algorithm,
you can see that now,
if we kind of install all this
node packages or dependencies
at a higher level of the monorepo folder,
you can see that if
you have these packages
under a node modules folder like,
you have A, B, C,
and C taking a dependency internally
on B, 2.0 under the node module folder.
Also, you can see that
there are symlinks created
to package one and two
so that say, if package three
later on takes a dependency
on package one, it can still be resolved
with the node module resolution algorithm.
This concept is called package hoisting.
This is really great
because this means that
we can now have some tools
which can help us achieve,
you know, package management
a lot easier, right?
Some of the tools that you
can use for managing packages
in your monorepo are rush JS,
there's something that
Microsoft open so is long back.
We also have yarn workspaces,
you can also use pnpm workspaces,
you can use, a tool called Lerna.
So, in our monorepo we
use yarn workspaces,
let's just see how it works, right?
To use yarn workspaces,
you add a package.json
in the monorepo root folder.
You can set private to true,
add a configuration around
what packages need to be
managed by workspaces.
You can also use like a regex pattern
for having all packages
under a certain folder
so that like you can
continue adding new packages
and you don't have to
change this configuration.
Additionally, you can also have like
a no hoist configuration,
say if you have some packages
where you don't want to hoist them
to the monorepo root level,
you can exclude them from hoisting.
And then all you need to do is run yarn
from the root of the monorepo.
So the package installation
time for, I mean,
we use 150 plus packages.
So this actually came down from 20 minutes
that we used to struggle
before to six minutes.
So this really improved
a lot of developer
productivity time, right?
The next aspect that we'll look at is
how to orchestrate actions or commands
across packages in a monorepo,
some of the popular tools to
achieve this Rush.js again,
you have Lerna, you can also
use a task kernel like Gulp,
you can also, if your
monorepo is simple enough,
you can even manage it with
simple Shell scripts, right?
We need these tools to perform
operations across packages,
usually from the root
folder of the monorepo.
So we use Lerna in our monorepo,
you can just look at how
insane the logo of Lerna is.
It's just quite mentored, right?
So for using Lerna,
what you need to do is add
a lerna.json configuration file
in the root of your monorepo, right?
So, that like you can
actually start running scripts
from the root folder itself.
You can add what packages
to run your commands
and then you can specify
which npmClient to use,
in our case, we are using yarn.
So we just add yarn,
you can also add the configuration
of useWorkspaces to true
if you're using yarn workspaces.
So there's options,
so if you are not using yarn workspace
or pnpm workspaces, you can
actually set it to false.
If you're using, if you set it to true,
that one is that you get is a Lerna
whenever it's trying to run the commands,
it kind of leverages the
workspaces dependency
add resolution a lot easier, right?
So what learner does is it
automatically figures out
the dependency tree, if
there are some packages
which require some other,
which take a dependency
on other local packages,
so which means that if you're
running a build command,
then it will require the
build command to be run
in other local packages first
and then a certain package.
So this way it executes the commands
for the packages in a certain order
of the dependency tree, right?
So all you have to do
is then Lerna run and
then the script name,
which can be run across
all the packages, right?
Let's see an example of
how we can use Lerna.
So here I have a type script
repo of four packages,
A B, C, and D
simple packages, nothing complicated.
It's just a sample that I've just written.
They all have similar set of
scripts in their package.json.
Here you can see that there
are some scripts like prepare,
watch, like run the build,
use webpack and so on.
You can also see that here package A
takes a dependency on B
and C internally, right?
Now, if you run Lerna and
watch in a panel mode,
you can see the order
in which the commands get executed, right?
So it actually first
shows that it executes
the watch command on C
and B packages first,
and then it runs the watch
command on the package A,
because he takes a dependency on B and C
and we need to ensure that
B and C are compiled first
and then you can try and
like watch on the files
in the package A.
So this really solves a lot of pain
if we need to execute some
commands in a certain order.
And this actually saves a
lot of time for us, right.
One of the other things
I really love about Lerna
is the scoping feature.
In our monorepo, we use
different test dev apps
for each of the experiences
like search people.
So I worked for the project search,
so what I need to do is I
need to just run commands
or watch on the code for all the packages
that mainly pertain to
search components, right?
I don't have to really execute
or watch on a components
that are in people experiences
if I don't have any dependency on them.
So, it actually helps us to do quick,
the validation, during development,
instead of integrating
with a different host apps
like Sharepoint Office.
We just use this test dev apps
to quickly validate our
code during development.
The Lerna scope command
allows you to only consider
a certain set of packages
instead of the whole monorepo, right?
So if you define the scope using Lerna run
and give the scope option,
and you can give the list of packages
that you want to scope
that are command too.
So this way it will allow
you to scope this commands
to a certain package.
It only executes the command
and one sub part of the dependency tree
and this actually was a huge
when for developer productivity.
Here, you can see,
we scope the command to package C,
it only runs for the package
C not for any other package.
So that way it actually says
a lot of time for us, right?
Some of the other very helpful
things that Lerna helps us
was to manage versions,
to publish packages,
to manage releases of these
packages really efficiently.
So it comes with commands like publish,
especially like some commands
like diff and changed
allow you to closely
monitor the change log
between any two releases very easily.
Let's look at some of the
things that we got out of Lerna.
So Lerna actually helped us
bring down our bill times
by more than 5x.
So even our watch times
are improved so much
and we continuously are trying to improve
how we can in like, for a developer,
how the productivity is
always increased, right?
Lerna also has a very
good community adoption,
which means it's quite reliable.
It is adopted by popular
JavaScript monorepo like,
babel, react-router, jest and many more.
To sum it all up, finally
pick the right tools for your monorepo,
if you're going for a TypeScript monorepo,
you need not necessarily choose the tools
that we've discussed,
but based on the complexity
of the packages that you have,
you can improve the developer experience
and ensure that you're
picking the right set of tools
that are conducive and
really usable for your team
and something that your
team feels comfortable with.
For linting unit or
functional and perf testing
you can always combine
it with tools like Lerna
to easily run commands across packages.
Additionally, if you're using TypeScript,
you should remember to ensure that
you manage TypeScript compilation
and manage typing generator properly
so that you can leverage intellisense
and that also helps in
improving deliver productivity
to basically have a good, robust code
that can come out of the developers.
These are some references
to all the content
that I've talked about in the stack.
One of my friends, Vincent
has written a detailed article
on how we avoid a large
mono repository, right.
So you also have links to Rush,
Lerna and yarn workspaces,
so you can go through it
and learn more about them.
And yeah, so finally,
thank you, thanks a lot.
That's all in the talk.
Thank you very much.
I really hope this was
very helpful for you.
You can reach out to me on Twitter,
if you have any questions
or perhaps the live Q and A
that might follow now.
So reach out to me @jaisanth
on Twitter anytime, right?
Thank you, thank you so much.
Hope you enjoyed this talk.
Have a wonderful conference.